All right, let's talk about the different task queues and
start off with the push queue which is the most
common one. The execution of push queues are managed by
App Engine itself. This means that App Engine has worker threads
that scan these queues and pick up tasks. These threads
then call a URL that you have specified when you
insert the task in the queue. This means that the
execution is broken out from the HTTP request response flow since
App Engine provide the threads to execute the tasks.
But the code used to process each task is still
provided by you, since you provide the URL that
the worker threads call. The best of two worlds, a
generic execution methodology,. That works with code that you
write. So the worker thread picks up task by task
and calls your url for each of them. And this
behavior continues for all the tasks in the queue until
the queue is empty. By default, the maximum execution duration
for a task is ten minutes. It is of course up
to you when you develop the application to split up
the work into tasks that can be completed within this time,
for example 100 mails each. There are many different configuration
options for queues in the following screen, we will look at
some of them. First to note is that the queues of
the find in the queue configuration file when you do development.
All queues have a queue name. For all applications,
half engine order provides a default queue with the name
default. This queue can be used without adding anything to
the queue configuration file but you may want to change
its default options, in which case you need to
define it in the file. Other things you can configure
are the performance parameters such as, the rate of processing,
the maximum rate in case of traffic peaks. The bucket
size and the maximum number of concurrent tasks that can
be executed. There are also a lot of parameters surrounding
error management. So now we've talked about how to define
a queue. Let's finish this part by looking at how to
create a task and assign it to a queue for
execution. The first thing you do is get the queue by
the queue name then you create the task and set
options such as the task name, the url to process the
task, another parameter such as performance and retry
options and finally you add the task to the
queue for execution. Finally, it is important that you
to protect the URL so only administrators can access
them through the permission settings. You don't want external
users to be able to execute your task logic
should they get ahold of these URL's. That was
a lot of theory, but that's it for now.
Now the time is come for you to do some work because we
have an exercise coming up where you will use push queues. Good luck.